[Music]
one of the things that most amazed by at
the moment is how the ideas and issues
that we're talking about every week here
on the Rubin report are relevant not
just in America but all over the world
the amount of email I'm getting from you
guys across the globe whether it's
Sweden Australia Brazil hungry or Japan
is actually staggering it really seems
to me that there has been a reawakening
as to what being a free human being is
all about you are in charge of your own
life and if you start with this simple
premise you can accomplish anything
while the discourse on social media may
seem more toxic than ever I see a
growing dynamic group of people coming
together through ideas and conversation
regardless of where they were born or
the color of their skin
we're partnering with learn Liberty
again this week and our guest is Rajshri
Agarwal she was born in India to a
traditional family only moved to America
where she now teaches about capitalism
at the University of Maryland where she
is the chair and professor of
entrepreneurship
she believes that capitalism provides
maximum freedom and happiness to all
people regardless of race religion or
anything else the ideas of freedom that
once sparked in her as a young child are
the same ideas that she's now helping
further by teaching minds of young
people today that is what freedom is all
about if you want to join me in
spreading these ideas of freedom and
individuality in person I'll be joining
Jordan Peterson on his twelve rules for
life tour for as many dates as I can
possibly fit in we kicked off the tour a
couple weeks ago at the beacon in New
York City where the energy in the room
was absolutely bananas I'll be traveling
with Jordan to the UK to speak in London
at the Apollo Hammersmith theatre on May
13th and then on May 14th I have the
incredible honor of speaking at the
Oxford Union hopefully I'll get to meet
as many of you guys as possible and I
also promise to down as many pints as
possible I'm also working on an
Australian tour and hope to have some
more info on that for you guys soon you
know I've mentioned on the show lately
that the endless hysteria of the left
and the politically correct craziness
that were caught up and was eventually
gonna drag me back into stand-up comedy
and this finally came to fruition this
past Sunday at the Irvine improv the
show was billed as an evening of stand
up and sit down
as I did about an hour of stand-up and
then Bob Saget joined me on stage for
about 45 minutes of a sit-down
it was awesome meeting so many of you
guys out there in the show was a huge
success the manager of the Improv even
told me that it was the first sold-out
standing ovation she's seen at the club
in her 18 years we're gonna announce
travel dates for upcoming stand-up gigs
pretty soon and I hope that you guys
will join me for at least a two-drink
minimum and plenty of laughs and finally
after years in the making we taped our
interview with dr. Thomas soul yesterday
on location at Stanford University in
San Francisco we flew our whole team up
there and rented a studio to make it
happen it was truly a personal and
career highlight for me and I can't wait
to share our sit-down with you next week
big thanks to our supporters on patreon
who make interviews like this possible
so all these announcements aside whether
you're in the US India Oxford San
Francisco or anywhere else we're all in
this fight together keep fighting for
what you believe in and I'll do the same
[Music]
we're continuing our partnership with
learn liberty today and joining me is
the Rudolph pilla moan chair and
professor of entrepreneurship at the
University of Maryland as well as the
director for the ED Snyder Center for
enterprise and economics Rhodri Agarwal
welcome to the Rubin report thank you
for having me Dave I feel we're gonna
have a very good talk because we've
already sort of had the interview before
we started we've been doing it already
I'm looking forward to this because we
did meet once before we were at a
conference in DC that was sort of
focusing on academia and free speech and
we spent a couple of minutes talking and
what I thought was interesting yeah I
don't think you knew who I was before
ending that I didn't know who you were
beforehand and they sort of brought me
there to talk a little bit about how
YouTube plays a part in reaching young
people and technology and all that and
you were very interested in that so we
didn't really focus on free speech
together but we focused on how
technology is shifting the conversation
so just very quickly to start why are
you interested in how technology is
affecting the conversation related to
free speech capitalism the whole thing
so I'm not interested in technology per
se but I'm interested in technology
because it represents the manifestation
of the human mind at work ultimately
what is technology technology is better
machines but what are machines
ultimately whether they're fast
computers or whether they're the
industrialized age engines or whatever
you call it right they are ways for us
humans to make our lives easier by using
machines so technology ultimately is a
way for humans to communicate better to
live better lives and to use their mind
in doing so yeah so I study innovation I
study technology because it enables us
to be the best we can be by using our
mind I was very proud when you walked in
here because you study innovation and
entrepreneurship and this is my garage
that we turned into a studio so I
thought yes and think about all of the
creativity that went into it right not
just by you but all of the things all of
the the techniques the machines that
we're looking around it was someone's
mind that had to come up with it first
so creativity which is at the heart of
individual enterprise is what I love and
that's what I study all right so that's
what we're gonna spend most of this hour
talking about and you know when we do
these shows with Liron Liberty they
always send me just a quick one-page bio
on everybody and I really loved yours
there was a bunch of quotes in there
that I that I want to quote directly to
you but you should know that when they
asked me to write that bio I dish that
out in about 15 minutes at 4:30 in the
morning oh look at you patting yourself
on the back but first let's talk a
little bit about your history because
you have an interesting history you were
born in India and you lived there for
that for your first 21 years talk a
little bit about that well I was born to
a very very traditional family Hindu
family my father was your typical rags
to riches on the
he embodied enterprise and he in fact
I'll tell you about this one story I was
in fifth grade and I came home so upset
because the history lesson that I had
just heard was all about how the United
Kingdom Britain came in and just
plundered this golden peacock that was
India and look at all the nasty things
that they did to us and how oppressed
and victimized we were and my father who
is a very much a traditional Orthodox
Hindu at that time said no actually
Britain did more good for India than
they did bad and it's like huh what do
you mean by that and he went on to talk
about why before that it's true that
India was rich but what did rich mean it
meant that the kings and the traders
were rich but there was a very feudalist
economy at that time and of course they
were also very balcan eyes because each
of these kingdoms were fighting with
each other so one of the things that he
talked about is how the advent of the
British you know they bought the rule of
law they bought infrastructure they gave
us English as a language you know often
people my husband says oh wow you talk
better English than I do and it's like
yes that's because I was educated in
English as well yeah but at the same
time that he was such entrepreneur in
his mindset he was very traditionalist
in his views of how women should be and
so when I was 12 years old he said to me
the right and the responsibility of
finding a husband for you is mine don't
you forget that and of course any woman
in his family couldn't work because that
was a slap on his face in his ability to
provide for us but if you think about it
at 12 years old I'm being told that the
two biggest decisions any individual can
make for themselves
will you marry and what you choose to
work in and I and I and I tell you know
I'd like to think that those two
decisions under grid everything that we
do both at work and they're not work
life that we live
if those are taken away from you what
does that mean
about you as an individual you as a
person
so between 12 and 18 I had to navigate
that distance because at 12 years old I
was a daddy's girl
I said of course that just please do me
a favor find me a husband who lives in
Bombay because I can't even bear the
thought of being in a city that's
different from you and at 18 I had to
see for myself that I couldn't renege on
that decision so between 18 and 21 was
really my discovery of who I wanted to
be and at 21 I left India two suitcases
in my hand left everybody that I loved a
very generous inheritance my father did
not speak to me for seven years Wow I
mean there's there's so much there of
your formative stuff that leads you to
where you're at right now when you came
home that day in fifth grade you learn
something in school and then you hear
something different from your father who
you obviously respected and admired and
had as you said rags to riches had
provided a good life for you guys how
did you go back to school after that I
mean did you go back and start arguing
with teachers is that even these arguing
with teachers I've in fact I'd remember
my science teacher saying Rajshri why do
you ask so many wise pretty sure that's
not what a science teacher is supposed
to say that's right that's really
fascinating so you picked up and left
yes and and left an inheritance all this
you you get to America just tell me a
little bit about that initial experience
so for me this was freedom it was you
know I had lived in India especially in
the generation that I was in a woman
didn't a girl or a woman did not live by
themselves right they got they stayed
with their parents so they were married
and then they went to their husband's
house so the concept of really being
yourself and having the responsibility
to make your own choices is both
liberating but then I
also realize I can't blame my parents
for my mistakes anymore
indeed five years later when my mom or
six years later when my mom came to
visit with us my husband said you know
what is the one biggest difference that
you see in your daughter and this will
tell you a little bit about my
personality there too she says to him
she's become very responsible wow that's
fascinating action and she's uses this
as evidence she says you know our her
father used to give her a very generous
allowance but we were we would marvel at
the fact that this kid would go through
this allowance within ten or twelve days
and then she'd say I'd like more and
then her father would sometimes give it
and sometimes there's no that's all
you're gonna get so then she'd come to
me or she'd come to her brother or I
started to tutor because I often said I
own my own bread and butter but my
father provided we might put with the
chance but one of the things that she
said was now she looks at me and she
realizes just how responsible I've
become that we're before money would
just flow off of my fingers and I
wouldn't give it a second thought
I had become so much more responsible in
my thinking and I think she was talking
a lot more about than just money in
India I was rebelling mm-hmm
because I was fighting against something
I came to the United States I didn't
have to fight against anything so I had
to figure out who I was and what I
really wanted to be yeah and it allowed
me to thrive yeah so you mentioned you
didn't talk to your father for seven
years after that had it how did the
reconciliation at it or was it a
reconciliation in fact one of the things
that I really really treasure is you
know for the I was a daddy's girl
and I did want his approval and after I
got my PhD I remember this one
conversation that I had with him where I
was this prodigal daughter he was just
finally talking to me again I think he'd
given up on the fact that I would be
this person that would ultimately come
home with my tail between my legs and
say you know you were right I was wrong
he just completely given up on that
and so he was listening to me and of
course I was trying to impress him so I
was talking to him about all of these
achievements as a young assistant
professor I'd received a couple of
awards I was getting to go to these
prestigious conferences and he's
listening but there's silence on his
side and the more I'm talking the more
he's silent and then finally I just gave
I had nothing more to brag about or talk
about and I wasn't getting me I'm so
proud of you from him and so there was
this uncomfortable silence after which
he says it's a phrase in Hindi which
roughly translated says if a peacock
dances in a forest who sees so who cares
and his point to me was you can be all
of the peacock you are but if you're not
next to me it doesn't mean anything so
that was the harshness that we started
off with even in the reconciliation but
my last visit with him paradoxically was
when I was asked to give a keynote in
India this was immediately after India's
liberalisation it was thriving as an
economy that we now know it to be and so
I was asked to give a keynote at an
academic conference on entrepreneurship
and economic growth and so on my way to
this conference I stopped by and ten
years after I have done my PhD I'm
finally talking to my father about my
research and connecting it to his own
entrepreneurial spirit and him being a
serial entrepreneur and I can finally
see the pride in his eyes you got I got
there and then at the keynote at the end
of this thing when you go to India you
realize that when you give a speech
they'll give you a present so in front
of about 500 people they give me this
present that I open and believe it or
not it's a peacock seems bidding seems
yes there's so much there and it's so
obvious hearing the story how it led to
all of the things that you're teaching
about now and care about the concept
between the battle between sort of
traditionalism yes
and then the
tripping Oriole spirit is really a
fascinating one because he obviously had
that yes he built something for himself
built a good life and then still wanted
that piece of sort of the old world and
I think we all kind of struggle with
that in a way maybe that's what the
struggle of Western civilization is and
I actually think that this relates to
often the need to think and integrate
one's psychological growth with one's
growth in the material and in the riches
realm so one of the things that I think
my father was as a paradox unfortunately
and I think that caused him as well as
me so much of this angst between us is
that at the same time that he applied
his intellect into the economic realm he
psychologically did not necessarily
realize that you know part of the reason
he was successful is because he was able
to make his own decisions which also
meant the freedom to make your own
mistakes and learn from your mistakes so
while he allowed that there as far as
his family was concerned there was this
very protectionist I need to take care
of you right but that I'm realizing this
as a parent is not very conducive to
your children's growth because what you
really need to give them are the tools
to make their own decisions as opposed
to telling them you know this is the way
you should do it yeah and ironically had
you not broken away and been free
although although he may have been very
pleased with your life and who knows
what your life would be and maybe you
maybe you would be happy in some ways it
wouldn't have led you to all this so you
had to directly I have to do that yes so
so one more thing about India before we
move on to everything else you're doing
I told you right before we started that
I get a ton of fan mail from India I
think there's some really interesting
political things happening right there
that seem to be driving people to
watching shows like this just give me
one thing that we should know about
India right now that maybe we don't know
as
which i think is probably probably
everything because India never comes up
in the news really yes so so I I can
talk about India right now a little less
than I can talk about the India that I
grew up in and why growing up in India
actually fostered my entrepreneurial
spirit okay so we can do it a little bit
a little bit of that right and I think
that that is one of the aspects this
definitely selection at play right I do
think that across every culture people
individuals are born tabula rasa some
cultures are much more conducive to
having the entrepreneurial spirit bloom
and as a result you see people go so
much farther but there are other cults
and other cultures stifle it but as
individuals I think we all have the same
proclivity to be the persons that we can
be but one of the things that I will
always credit in my education in India
is the focus on thinking and critical
thinking and intellectualism so the
concept of a nerd growing up for me was
unheard of because the coolest kids were
also the ones that participated in
science and elocution debates you know I
was always at the forefront I wasn't so
much of a sports person but I was very
much in debates in elocution
competitions and science competitions
and so on and that was cool that was a
United States right so the concept that
there's a nerd and a nerd is socially
awkward was was unheard off for me I'll
give you another example you know my
brother was the one that first talked to
me about Iran and of course in that
journey that I was telling you about
where I had to find my own identity
reading Atlas Shrugged was really the
pillar of strength and helped me
identify my own sense of life but the
way I read Atlas Shrugged you'd find
very funny is in colleges in India if
you're a guy and you want to impress a
chick you carry at least in my time a
paperback novel of Atlas Shrugged in
your back pocket
because that means that you're
intellectually you're thinking now I was
also said it was also said that's so
fascinating right and it's also said
well if you're young then you believe in
these views but then you grow up and you
grow over it
I have never grown over it I think that
that aspect of the mind the ability to
think through decisions is one that I
will credit the Indian culture and my
father for endowing in me yeah well
you'll be happy to know as I mentioned
to you before that you know I was at the
students for liberty conference and I
met several students from India who were
there that are involved with Iran
Institute consider themselves
Objectivist and all that and it seems
that some of those ideas at least are
thriving there so yes yes that brings it
into the modern day okay so as I
mentioned I really loved your bio and
there were a couple of great quotes in
there some but I want to read one
directly to you you said my passion is
upward mobility integrated across
intellectual psychological and economic
realms I care deeply about growth
achievement for me is measured not by
the level you have attained as much as
the road you have traveled for me the
journey is the destination and I care
deeply about integrity as in the whole
of a person rather than the individual
parts and I thought there's obviously a
lot there but it seems to me that this
is sort of what we're missing these days
we've got people that are just screaming
at each other all the time that
everyone's pretending they're an expert
in everything nobody sort of listening
you know I've been traveling with Jordan
Peterson a lot who's talking so much
about what I think is such simple stuff
in a certain way although he's quite
brilliant at it you're talking about
personal responsibility and being a full
person and I thought that that was
really what you were getting to hear yes
so what's the question so the question
is well I guess I sort of know why you
came to believe yes but we seem to have
a real lack of an ability to be a full
integral person these days I think in
part it really relates to this
entrepreneurial mindset and a growth
mindset and for me personally
is a perspective that is in some sense
selfish let me explain by what that I
mean by that and I mean selfish in a
very positive way Here I am right now an
endowed professor I'll just give you an
example of it right and I get to mentor
a lot of young minds and many of them
come to my office particularly PhD
students with this mindset of I know so
much it is true I know a lot but think
about the interaction between a student
and a professor where if the professor
says I know everything you're my student
and you're gonna learn from me it's a
one-way street it's the student
benefiting from the professor with that
mindset but how is the professor
benefiting from it where is my learning
where is my growth
so in this conversation one of the ways
that I approach this relationship is I
say you have to start this conversation
thinking of each other as intellectual
equals I may know more than you but
especially in the realm of research
which is creating new knowledge I need
you to have an questioning mind because
what happens if you're saying something
that I want to challenge and after all
in academia we're in the marketplace for
ideas if I challenge you and your mind
immediately shuts down because you say
Oh Rhodri said this she's the expert
professor she knows everything and
you're not gonna challenge me then
you're not allowing yourself to learn
but more importantly if I know that
about you I'm gonna shut myself down and
I am going to censor myself from
expressing my ideas because I want your
mind to be open so now we both knows and
we've both silenced ourselves so this is
just one example of where I think that
this this focus on growth and unlearning
is actually very liberating and in that
sense very selfish for me because now it
becomes a two-way street
I'm not just teaching
I'm also learning how do you get over
the concept that selfishness is somehow
evil that I think a lot of people
believe this inherently you say well I'm
selfish and they think well you're evil
so this actually relates to one of this
point about the lack of integration or
this thinking about either/or so the
common concept of selfishness is as in
well you're only thinking about yourself
and not thinking about the other why why
does it have to be an either/or why
Cannot it be a win-win trade which is
fundamentally recognizing your dignity
my dignity your identity my identity and
knowledge that should we've you know
right now you and I are talking why are
we sitting here and having this
conversation other than the fact of
course that you know we're passionate
about these ideas and we find that our
time together is meaningfully well-spent
so my enjoyment out of this conversation
is not at your expense
neither is what you're gaining out of it
at my expense in fact we're creating
value together yeah I like that you
brought it into this room because that
that's exactly right for me at least
it's like in a way I'm doing something
selfish and that I'm doing my show and
bringing a guest on that you know will
hopefully get people to watch right and
you're here because you want your ideas
to spread the people that are watching
this hopefully are getting something out
of it for themselves I mean that's what
people really need to understand that
that's what's integral about this it
doesn't mean we're taking from you it
actually means that we're giving side to
ourselves and something yes and so for
me this notion that selfishness means
this brute that is just gonna ride
roughshod over everybody else's rights
and responsibilities fundamentally does
not get to this idea that each of us
have a right to live our lives the way
we see best and you know take the
consequences good or bad of our
decisions how much of this do you think
is about just whether people view humans
fundamentally as good
or evil so if you fundamentally think
people are evil and you say to someone
be selfish well then it is that they're
gonna run roughshod over everybody and
destroy the environment and steal money
and kill people and all that versus if
you believe people are fundamentally
good or at least neutral then if they do
something for themselves it will
potentially be so for me the only evil
is really the use of force to throttle
somebody else you can do what you want
to do so long as you're not infringing
on other people's rights and
responsibilities and their ability to
live their life the way they do and
indeed in a civil society that is the
fundamental respect that we all each
other that I live my life the best way
that I think is done but I'm not gonna
impose my views on you I may have a
conversation with you about my views and
you're free to agree or disagree with my
views and free to agree or to interact
or not with me but I can't force my
views and my beliefs on you and neither
should you force I mean that's
fundamentally the conversation between
my from my father and I think about it
right it is that we were both very
aligned when our views 80% of the time
but the 20% where he thought that as a
father he had the right to tell me what
I should do as opposed to be the
facilitator and guide an adviser to my
decisions that is the fundamental
disconnect do you think we spend too
much time on that 20% or you know I
think I heard Barry Weiss on real time
called the narcissism of small
difference yes where we we can agree on
almost everything yeah philosophically
and then we find something yes and then
that is what we focus on and it really
depends upon is that something in a
hierarchy of your values a fundamental
issue that you do need to disagree on or
is that something in the hierarchy of
your values and your beliefs something
that is not as critical to the
conversation that we're having
I prefer indeed I am a big believer in
win-win outcomes I don't you know my
husband is my best friend I love him the
last thing I would want is for him to
say rush Rae I'm with you not because it
gives me any selfish joy not because I
get any pleasure I take pity on you I
feel sorry for you and that's why my
life's objective is to take care of you
what do you want to be in that
relationship I walk out the door I'd say
if I am NOT giving you personal
satisfaction and joy in being with me if
I'm not your best friend just like your
mind then this relationship is not a
win-win yeah and I don't want to be
either an object of charity or pity or I
don't want you to feel like you're
obligated yeah
so I want to back up to saying you said
a few minutes ago about the way that you
teach and that exchange between
professor and student where it's it's
sort of you trying to look at each other
as equals and I might learn something
from them and they might learn something
for me so so two parts of that first of
how often do you find that you actually
learn something
oh every time indeed last year
University of Maryland honored me with
the distinguished scholar teacher award
and one of my first slides was about
exactly that the debt that I owe to my
advisor who incidentally gave me away
when Rob and I got married remember my
father wasn't talking to me my advisor
was my second father and so I learned a
lot from him and I have benefited from
that learning of a mentor advisor
relationship but I have benefited
equally from paying it forward so every
one of my PhD students I can pinpoint to
you exactly what ideas they helped me
learn which empirical context and
innovative industries I went into along
with them and how my own scholarship has
fundamentally benefitted and even
changed trajectories because of my PhD
students so the second part of that then
would
do you think that is a real rarity on
college campuses these days that that
professors are willing to learn from
students because when I go to colleges
which I'm doing all the time now one of
the things I hear most is that students
are actually afraid to challenge their
professors because they think it's going
to hurt their grades and that generally
just generally speaking this seems to
come from more leftist professors that
if you challenge them on
intersectionality or any of that that
they have people actually think their
grades will suffer do you think that
that's it it is unfortunately I you know
I there's this part of me in my soul
that says that just cannot be true
please let this not be true because the
fundamental identity of an academic
should be one which is focused on
learning and focused on ideas and indeed
I would say that one requires a
confidence and a self-esteem and to be
comfortable with being challenged and so
often I do have several colleagues that
I worry about in as much as they don't
make good advisers and part of the
reason they don't make good advisors is
not because they are not experts in
their sphere but precisely because they
cannot stand being challenged by their
students and in my opinion that's a
lose-lose not only are you steaming the
students growth you're signing your own
growth yeah so when you hear people
talking about the free speech issues on
college campuses and at the conference
that we were at I mean there were
literally hundreds of professors there
to talk about how do we defend free
speech that was the whole purpose of it
do you sense that something has shifted
in the last couple years does it seem
worse now I give you my own personal
story about three years two years ago I
ended up writing an op-ed in the
Washington Post on confessions of a
silenced professor now you've heard me
these last 15 20 minutes anyone that
knows me says rush reuse silence
give me a break easily silence exactly
and indeed part of the theme of that
op-ed was a very important
self-realization that I had and that was
that I was now starting to think do I
really want to take this on and it was a
colleague of mine who we were just
having a conversation about something
that had happened at a conference and
she said to me when I was like you know
I'm wondering should I weigh in on this
or should I just let it go and the point
is not what the issue was the point is
that I even asked that question which is
what this colleague said to me she says
Rajshri when did you become so afraid of
speaking your mind and that really hit
me in my gut if you will it's like when
did I start thinking if I do this what's
going to be to fall out within the
academic circles
should I repress myself and that's when
I realized that the spiral of silence
where we end up so you know you can talk
about censorship
I actually think at the University of
Maryland I am in a great university
president on down we have a investment
and a dedication towards freedom of
speech and thinking about the academia
as a marketplace for ideas so great to
hear I mean I just before I came here I
had a phenomenal conversation with the
president regarding an event where we're
worried about whether or not there is
going to be some backlash because of
some of the people that we're bringing
in in a debate but for us it's very
important to have that reasoned and
respectful discourse but for me it was
you know people from the outside can
tell you whatever they want but when you
start to silence yourself that's when
you silence your mind that's when you
don't let your innovative creativity you
know what is freedom of speech about it
is not the freedom to agree it's the
freedom to disagree but doing so in a
manner and again coming back to this use
of force right I can
say what I want I am NOT you know III in
college campuses these days one of the
things that they say is well words can
hurt you know I was in a convent and the
teachers used to say sticks and stones
can break my bones but words don't hurt
me right and yes words do have a power
I'm not denying that for sure several of
the things that my father said to me
psychologically were very wounding and I
had to work through that so I'm not
denying the fact that words in the
psychological and intellectual realm are
very powerful but the point is is a
fundamental difference between words and
coercion as in now I am forcing you to
think otherwise because words are
fundamentally our minds thinking and
then communicating with each other yeah
we've had a long sort of slippery road
on this right where people's are
starting to think that words mean action
or that you have some sort of right to
not be offended or a right to comfort I
mean you just simply don't have those I
think actually it's the converse is true
you need to be courageous to look at
something and say this doesn't accord
with my beliefs so you know they let me
use a different analogy out here people
often talk about open versus closed mine
I actually think neither of those
concepts makes sense because what is a
closed mind that is the professor that
you and I were just talking about who
says I'm right how dare you challenge me
I've made up my decisions already right
but an open mind is someone that's just
sitting on the fence not willing to take
any kind of a committed stand in fact I
would prefer a closed mind to an open
mind in that way right but what I really
care about is an active mind that I have
some opinions some beliefs and they're
based on the prior thinking that I have
done but I'm not omniscient
I'm not infallible I could have made
mistakes in my thinking so having an
active mind allows me the gives me the
permission to say I
do you have these thoughts and beliefs
but if someone provides me with
compelling evidence and compelling logic
that would make me change my thinking
then it isn't my best interests to do so
yeah you know it's funny I find I often
I sit across brilliant people all the
time and every now and again someone
dropped something that I think wow
that's what I've been trying to get to
active mine I mean I'm gonna start using
that phrase because that's right you
don't just want an open mind of of
endless nothing actually and you don't
want to close my but an active mind keep
keep working - thank you Dan yeah so I
want to ask you one other thing on this
and then I really want to focus on all
the stuff that you're teaching yes for
the whole second half what do you think
the actual solution is related to this
so if a professor like you has this
sudden need or fear of self censoring
and I think it's pretty obvious to me
how open and and courageous you are
inherently what do you think the
solution is and when we were at this
conference a lot of the professor's were
saying this has to come from the donors
because the administrators at the
schools cannot be brave enough if they
think that their jobs are on the line
all the time
but that the one way to do it is that if
the donors are slowly turning off the
money to professors that won't defend
free speech or administrators who won't
back the professors who do that that
might be the change does that make sense
to you yes and I disagree with it let me
explain to you why I disagree with it oh
you cannot so this comes back to the
first question you asked me why do I
focus on integrity and why do I think
about economics which is money and
donors along with psychological and
intellectual growth for me you cannot
have one without the other these are
pieces of an intent that that fit
together to make an integrated whole
within academia one always has to worry
about the fact that you've got all of
these pressures Russians for conformity
pressures for funding and resources that
are coming in there what you really care
and which you cannot renege if you are
an intellectual entrepreneur which is
truly what being in academia is all
about being an intellectual entrepreneur
is your unwavering focus on knowledge
creating knowledge and if I if I may say
so on truth resources just like any
venture capitalist so this intellectual
entrepreneur may be a good analogy
actually venture capitalists provide you
with the financial resources but they
are complimentary resource providers
they cannot tell you which direction
should you go nor should they right if
you don't have that creative mindset
that intellectual horsepower if you're
not courageous enough to go for that
then any kind of pressure from the
venture capitalists is not gonna help
nor are any kind of pivots and
directions and so on so the way I look
at it is I do not and will not ever
change my research based on what donors
may or may not give on the contrary I
will look for aligned donors because you
cannot put the cart before the horse you
cannot put your purpose behind the money
or the success metrics of your purpose
your purpose has to drive all of the
other resources that you garner so if an
administrator lacks courage that's on
the administrator first and foremost if
an academic lacks courage of conviction
that's on them you can have
complimentary people aligned with you
kind of helping you along the way but
they cannot substitute for that
fundamental Drive that you need to have
all right so everything that we spent
the first 30 some-odd minutes talking
about it sort of leads to academic
integrity yes it sounds like to me that
these that we need not only the the
students to have some integrity but the
administrators the professor's
everything else everyone at the
university altogether do you think
that's a fair assessment to do
absolutely in fact I
that we often confuse the terms academic
freedom and academic integrity would we
really care about his academic integrity
first and foremost and academic
integrity really means that I'm not
gonna sell my soul or my ideas based on
the highest bidder I believe that you
know and this is again the search for
truth that requires integrity and then
of course I have the freedom to
collaborate with people including donors
on areas where we find mutually
beneficial relationships and win-win
trade yeah so one of the things that you
talked about I referenced it earlier in
one of these quotes that you really
focus on is upward mobility yes and it I
think it's particularly interesting
right now because if you listen to some
of our political leaders it seems like
we've sort of completely lost the
ability that we you know we're separated
by class and all that you come from a
place where upward mobility was very
hard it's gotten less hard as they've
embraced as India has embraced
capitalism first I guess in the most
broad sense tell me why you think upward
mobility is so important but more
importantly what's the state of it in
America right now so I actually think
that we in the United States
focus on upward mobility as if this was
a major problem in the u.s. other
countries are becoming more
market-oriented
than the United States the United States
still stands as the one place where you
really really have the ability to be
upwardly mobile and I think that is the
greatest asset that the United States
still have and I'm very proud to call
this country my country of choice so
let's sit in that idea for a second
because I totally agree with it and it
seems to me that all of the people who
say that's not true are missing that our
laws here allow you to do whatever you
want with your life it doesn't mean that
you are gonna do it it doesn't mean that
it's going to be handed to
but as you just said as an immigrant
that came here that has become
tremendously successful you're living
proof that you can do it absolutely and
that still holds in fact in some ways I
think we so take these laws for granted
that we don't know what the rest of the
world is out there so my daughters have
grown up and been born in the United
States but I think that their biggest
learning moments come when they leave
the country and see things even in India
today as they as it exists they see the
disparities of the things that they can
take for granted versus in India but you
still have to fight with the corruption
you still have to fight with the status
aspects the United States is very status
free relative to most other countries
including India and there's a dignity to
human labor here that is often missing
in many other cultures that is the
aspect that I care about when I care
about upward mobility and you know what
let's be honest out here I did not have
the kind of privileges that my daughters
do I could be mourn the fact that you
know I came from a country or from a
traditional family values that I had to
the family tradition there was such that
I had to have this fight that for sure
defined me positively but also caused
some psychological scars and of course
my hope is that my daughter's don't go
through that and I could go there and
say you know what the level at which
they're starting off is so much higher
than the level I'm starting off and
aren't they privileged and look at all
that I didn't have or I can focus their
minds and their ideas at you know you
may start here but the definition of
your achievement is not your level but
where you end do you find it fascinating
that people are constantly attacking
that they are they attack people that
have a little bit more to start which is
the whole point of life you want your
children to have more the only way the
only way that it would be fair it is
not because I can't be raised to their
level right the only way to do it is to
bring them down to the level that I
started and how's that fair yeah right
and so again by focusing on the level
that one starts with as a measure of an
individual's achievement I think is not
necessarily focusing on their individual
effort and there are a lot of people
even in India you know as I said to you
my father went from rags to riches and
there were a lot of people that there
were my friends that were quite rich and
they had a very entitlement mentality
you know what I don't think that they're
any happier then I was even when I was
poorer so this comes back to the point
that you the quote that you had
I can't just measure a person's success
by their economic riches you also
happiness which is what I care about is
a state of mind it's a state of
consciousness that has to be earned
self-esteem when combined with the sense
of I'm materially at a place that I'm
comfortable or rich but more than that
psychologically and intellectually I
feel like I've made something of myself
I think Dad is something that is so much
more inspiring to go after money
you know it's neither used to say money
is the reward not the reason and I
completely agree with that yeah it's so
interesting because I've been thinking
about this a lot lately because
obviously the show is kind of catching
fire and I'm doing okay financially and
we're building something good and I'm
traveling a lot people say nice things
to me all the time and I've been
thinking about that and people keep
saying well you're gonna get some big
offer from one of these networks or
something but but I love this like I'm
actually happy now like I'm doing what I
think I'm supposed to be doing and I
don't know where that road goes but
looking at everything holistically it's
not just about money it's about doing
something that gives you value and all
that but we seem not to focus enough but
that's the point right I get so much joy
so again to that quote that you were
talking about for me the journey is the
destination you know whether
I feel younger today than I did when I
was 20 years old and what's the big
difference I feel like I have earned the
self-esteem not recognition outside
because people you know and you know
this you meet a lot of people and they
come to you and say hey Dave you're so
great but who is saying you're great
makes a big difference to you hearing
whether you see what I mean so there has
to be a sense of do I believe that
you're saying I'm great for the reasons
that I value and if that is there then I
will take external adulation as a
positive if not it's Hollow
it's empty so self-esteem is truly what
one should be striving for yeah do you
think at some level capitalism and maybe
the Western world in a wider sense is
suffering from success at the moment
that it almost seems like because we've
been so successful we're now going to
that place that we mentioned earlier
where we're just fighting over little
differences where then there's a lot of
people right now I mean if you talk
about socialism on college campuses
you'll you'll sell out the room you know
and if you talk about fortunately I find
when I go and I mostly talked to
libertarian or capitalist or whatever
groups you know we're doing quite well
as well but that the ideas that are
completely contrary to everything you've
just said seem to be gaining some
momentum so I don't think they're
victims of our success I think we're
victims of the fact that we have never
really sat down and thought seriously
about the reasons for our success and by
eschewing that intellectual thought and
ideas that under underpin our success we
have actually sold our success short how
should we have done that do you mean
odds that our politicians should have
talked about it more or you mean more in
academia I think it starts from K
through 12 education actually I think
that we have taken this concept we we
have short-circuited our mind in K
through 12 education all the way through
college and this comes back to your
example
the faculty advisor that does not want
to be challenged by their students when
you have the mentality as a teacher
whether it's in K through 12 or as a
professor in academia where I know what
is best and I am going to tell you what
it is as opposed to facilitate your
learning process we are not training our
students how to think anymore we're not
giving them the ability to learn in the
manner that they do I'll give you
another example
memorization taught off as a huge
negative today but you know Sir Anthony
Leggett who was a Nobel laureate was a
Nobel laureate and a professor at
Illinois which is where I was
give this inspiring speech to middle
schoolers one day and the theme of it
was the more you know the more you know
what you don't know knowledge is a
building on process you have to learn
first to then learn what you need to
learn again and so fostering that spirit
in students will then allow you to go
back to first principles so it's not
about being an expert on any area but
it's about any area that you choose to
go in there don't just look at the
outcomes don't just look at the success
factors and then try to emulate the
symptoms if you will or the the the
things that accompany success go down to
the very fundamental levels of what are
the ideas and what are the first
principles that enable success to begin
with it's interesting because this seems
to be a place where maybe technology has
harmed us because it's like instead of
having a holistic and integral view of
really knowing what you're talking about
well what do we do we google it so you
know you know maybe and maybe you'll get
there right maybe you'll get there we go
yeah but you but you'll get just the
quick answer instead of going to the
root of what your is where I'd say again
technology is a tool it does not absolve
us of our responsibility on how we use
the tool I like to be a huge fan of
Google
yeah Google Scholar has made my life so
much easier I remember being a doctoral
student having to go through Lockett
Lockwood library in 6 feet of snow in
Buffalo weather right if I wanted an
answer to a question now Google Scholar
allows me to do it in seconds know what
microfiche is exactly and I have a
microfiche to do my data gathering yeah
but but the point out here is I can use
Google Scholar to get just an amazing
amount of knowledge at my fingertips how
great is that
I mean I am so thankful to technology to
do that but that does not absolve me of
the responsibility of saying here is all
of the pieces of information in fact I
would say this age of information
technology the need of the mind to have
judgment and to discern across all these
pieces of information is at an all-time
high
yeah so obviously you teach and you talk
about entrepreneurial spirit and
entrepreneurship one of the things that
I think is fascinating related to
technology right now is that Peter Thiel
is leaving Silicon Valley because he
feels that collectivism leftism cultural
Marxism maybe you have some other
phrases for whatever that is has sort of
crushed the ability to think so that
there isn't the creativity coming out of
Silicon Valley that there used to be
which is why we don't have that many new
apps anymore we don't have that many new
breaking technologies and he is a
capitalist and he's ironically moving to
LA to become freer which is sort of
people don't think of us as a capitalist
Haven here in California and LA
specifically do you find that
fascinating that that Silicon Valley
seems to lean so far left and yet is
supposed to be the place of innovation
you know now that you're saying that I
just made a connection that I never
thought of my father represents exactly
that if you think about it right he was
very free market oriented as it came to
the economic realm and being
entrepreneurial in terms of creating new
products and services and economic
riches but when it came time to thinking
he was very traditional as
and I think that that bifurcation this
mind-body dichotomy if you will is
what's plaguing a lot of people right
now so I am NOT an expert on Silicon
Valley i have noticed of course that a
lot of people so facebook I just I just
saw a Mark Zuckerberg say something to
the effect of you should have economic
regulation on social media it's like huh
the whole reason why you were successful
it's because you did not have any
barriers to entry the best way to keep a
monopoly is to have government
regulation because again that's the use
of force right if I cannot go into an
industry because there is prohibition so
think about uber and what Hoover had to
deal with in the taxicab industry think
about when Airlines was not what we know
it because they were just that regulated
carriers right yeah that's eminent
monopoly and the best way for
entrepreneur who has achieved success
but now no longer wants to continue to
own their success is to say let me
create barriers to entry through
government regulation so I can be
protected by any entrepreneur such as me
right those days ago
right right to then come and infringe on
what I have it's almost as if he's
trying to protect what he has yeah think
maybe the thing you know it's so funny
also how these things change because you
know 15 years ago before over when I
lived in New York City basically my
whole adult life and people would
complain relentlessly about the cabs
they're all broken down their drivers
aren't friendly they don't pick you up
if you're a certain color etc etc then
uber comes around fixes a lot of these
problems by ingenuity and now people are
saying you see what they did they put
the cab's out of business the same
people who were upset the first in
Boston it's even worse in Boston every
uber or lyft ride has to be has to pay
five scientists cents of a surcharge and
every you know a fraction of that I
don't remember whether it's two cents or
three cents but you know
adds up when millions of right yeah goes
to the taxicab industry to the industry
that's actually being replaced by this
and doing a much better service yes yes
exactly so that just so then is there a
flaw in capitalism there somehow because
that there's probably some cronyism
that's allowing the politicians to write
these ridiculous laws loamy ISM is not
about markets cronyism is about statism
cronyism is not capital as a network it
is government regulation at work and it
this comes back to you know Dave you're
successful I take pride in watching your
videos simply because I enjoy it but
there I'm sure is a bit of envy to about
gee I wish I could be as eloquent as
Davis and as the five hundred thousand
people that watch the day Rubin show you
know Wow wouldn't I love to have that
kind of an impact
now that's enemy on my part there are
two things I could do it can either be a
positive driver of my energies I could
say I want what Dave does has but I
don't have and that can put me on a
growth mindset entrepreneurial mindset
what is it that I need to do in order to
achieve those success factors going back
to first principles what are the reasons
behind Dave's success and what can I do
to emulate or do differently than take
or I can say no I want what Dave has but
I don't need to earn it I don't need to
do that so let me get the government to
take some of what dave has some of the
sponsorship right and that's what income
inequality and redistribution is all
about I'm taking some of your viewership
and I'm going to be forcing those people
to now listen to me
so that's where we're using government
force whether it's income redistribution
or any kind of yardstick of value where
we re distributing we're saying we're
gonna take it from you
and that actually negates your viewers
rights right because
if I have the government saying that
then some of them would be forced to not
watch you but watch me yeah on the other
hand there's jealousy by the way the
difference between envy and jealousy one
of my colleagues just told me recently
envy is when I want something I don't
have jealousy is when I want to keep
something that I have but I'm being
threatened against right again positive
or negative if I feel jealousy because I
feel threatened about what I'm about to
lose I can go ahead and say what is it
that I need to do in order to keep it or
I can create barriers and say you can't
have it through the use of force the
same principles that work at cronyism at
both sides of the yardstick so when we
talk about relative poverty in the
United States as an income inequality by
the way coming from India I know what
true poverty is we in the United States
the minimum level of poverty here is so
much better than the rest of the world
so if we care again it's about envy
these rich people have what I don't have
and I should get them or on the rich end
of the spectrum I have this as a wealthy
person regardless of whether I got it
out of an inheritance all because of
prior entrepreneurial thinking it's
being threatened but I want to keep it
for myself so the best way for me to do
that is to lobby the government and
erect barriers to entry on both sides
the use of governmental regulation to
respond to envy and jealousy is a
negative not a positive driver of
economic growth so where do you where do
you draw the line or where is the
starting point then of what government
is supposed to do a government has a
legal monopoly on force as it should
because you and I in a civil society
cannot focus our mind our effort on
creating value if we're always gonna
worry about somebody looting or taking
things away from us right so I am NOT an
anarchist
I believe in government's I believe in
the rule of law I believe in the
protection so there are basic functions
of the government that absolutely are
essential beyond that keep the economy
away from the realm of the government
because the government's only ability to
do something is to say you in your best
judgment think you should go eh I am
Telling You you need to go B you're
forcing the mind to not think or act on
their best judgment yeah
so it's interesting in the in the case
of uber and what you were describing in
Boston and the pennies going back to the
to the cabbies who have nothing to do
with it
that actually is because of regulation
and that the only way to eliminate that
and let new businesses thrive is let
them thrive just let's just unleash them
let them go all right so there's a
couple more things that I want to do
with you and you had a for questions
about personal leadership then you asked
a lot of your students and I thought
that these were really great yes and and
it really this I think sort of puts a
nice bow on everything that we've talked
about here so the first one is what is
your purpose kids must be kids students
must be they must look at you kind of
kind of curiously when you ask them that
one because that's a that's a big one
yeah so let me spend two seconds just
telling you about why I came up with
this framework yeah I'm a strategy and
entrepreneurship professor and I was
asked to teach in a program which was
largely minority high school student
based and I was asked to give a lecture
on strategic management a strategic
management is typically the realm of
CEOs how can high schoolers identify and
associate with questions that a CEO has
to deal with that was the big challenge
that I had how am I supposed to talk to
them about at that time what Steve Jobs
is doing for Apple even though they
recognize Apple and make it real to them
and I realize I didn't need to do that I
could say to them especially because
there are thus cusp of identifying who
they are and creating their identity
you're the CEO of me incorporated are
you thinking like a CEO what are the
four fundamental question
that a CEO should ask and are you asking
those questions of yourself and it
begins with the first one is what is
your purpose the second is what does
success look like
the third is what's my value proposition
given that that's my purpose and that's
what success looks like and then finally
in this stumps a lot of people with whom
should I trade yeah so these four
questions I think are that the essence
of any entrepreneurial individual or any
entrepreneurial organization how often
when you ask these students these
questions do they have some good answers
oh my gosh these are tough I mean these
what is your purpose these are the
questions of all time exactly asking
them in the framework of business and
entrepreneurship or themselves actually
so III I'm actually agnostic about
whether they want to define what is your
purpose as it relates to their career or
as it relates to their life but the
answers that I provide them in the
context of thinking and you would be
amazed as to how much this resonates all
the way from beginning high schoolers
including my own daughter who was forced
to take this class with me to executives
in my Executive MBA so what is your
purpose really requires people to think
about what problems do I want to solve
that are meaningful to me so it again
comes to making the world a better place
to live by doing something important to
yourself and you know people say oh
making the world a better place to live
oh come on rush ray right but what is it
what is your world Dave what is my world
it's a place as you go the people you
meet and the things that you do and if
in doing these three things you have
solved a problem and made it a better
place then you've made a world a better
place but you've done it by focusing on
things that are important to you yeah
so it's interesting you you're talking
about all these things through the
business lens but this is really what
you're talking about you said before
which is which is happiness yes
absolutely yeah and in fact on that
point so what does success look like to
me it is the ability to say I love what
I do
and I'm good at it because
it's the virtuous spiral that enables
self-esteem and then you have
self-esteem because you're good at
something you want to invest in it to
become even better at it yeah it's
pretty cool waking up with that that
feeling so that was number two what does
exact success look like you mentioned
all of them already but I just want to
read a little bit so what is your value
proposition so notice that the answer to
the question what does success look like
takes an inward perspective what do I
love and then what are my abilities that
will help get me to where I love and
what I'm good at what is my value
proposition is still looking at your
abilities but now the yardstick is how
is it creating value to you so clearly I
love enterprise and innovation right
yeah I love what I do
I think I'm I'm pretty good at it you're
pretty good I come up every morning with
a spring in my step
but why would that cause you to wanna
use you know ask Rajshri to join you
this morning as opposed to multiple
other people that you do so what's my
value proposition to you what benefit do
I offer you with the features that are
unique to me that is the focus on value
proposition yeah and it's obvious
because we have the evidence right here
because of all the people that I talked
to that weekend you were one of I think
two people who I said to the learn
Liberty guys we're gonna get our own
show yeah you came up to me after we had
a great conversation about all of this
stuff and there you go and then finally
with who should I trade you think that
is the one thing that stumps a lot of
people and goes back to the what is my
purpose making the world a better place
to live by doing something important to
me right so providing benefit to someone
else but making sure that I'm benefiting
and I'm doing something I love to the
answer to what the success look like is
really getting to what you love doing
which is about you the answer to your
value proposition is providing benefit
to someone else right making the world a
better place to live with whom do you
trade is bringing those two together so
you and I are trading right now we may
not be
changing any dollars but there's a trade
going on out here and that relates to
your abilities and your aspirations and
my abilities and my aspirations and
we're combined together with a common
objective so the alignment of your
aspirations and my abilities are what's
gonna determine our actions and in doing
so I get to do what I love doing I offer
you a benefit so do you and it's a
win-win trade well I got to do what I
love doing here I feel that we I think
we did almost everything is there
anything that we possibly missed this
was this was truly a pleasure because
this was exactly what I've tried to do
in my life and with this show and
everything else and and your you just
exude exactly what you're talking about
thank you or joy to say yes and in fact
that's exactly why I want to trade with
you I love training with you right
because you exude the same positive
can-do sense of life and I would rather
have people around me that have that
same spirit make me better make me more
energized than people that either I
bring down or they bring down you know
or they bring me de can we do a live
event together can we do something all
right we're gonna make something happen
sounds good this was this was truly a
pleasure I'm glad it happened to
everyone and for more on Rajshri you can
check out her website which we've linked
to right down below
[Music]
you